[Music]  this is the day they arrived the object  touchdown 40 minutes ago Roma it's going  to happen I don't know dr. banks you're  at the top of everyone's list when it  comes to translations any words is that  yes am I the only one having trouble  sing is where they look like you'll see  soon enough they need to see me dr. mank  now that's a proper introduction war  objects have landed around the world  it's their language got to know what  hours to form a stock a little more  they're not our enemy we need to talk to  them it's more complicated than how is  it more complicated are you dreaming in  their language what does it say  my pen so how do we clarify their  intentions I go back in what is she  doing you are committing an act of  treason see you trust me thank you banks  language is the first weapon drawn and  conflict that's quite a greeting yeah  well you wrote it you are on the top  everyone's on this one close to choice